part two of the sex tape I'm kidding
joking we're done Democrats get tense
when Federman starts making sense yep
there's activity in his brain and it's
causing Democrats pain Senator and
former Adams Family Butler John fedman
is causing a rift within his party
breaking from the left most notably with
his outspoken support of Israel he went
from being unable to speak to too smart
for Harvard the hoodied hero is become a
fierce critic of runaway immigration
calling for a solution to the endless
border crossings it's almost as if
someone had loosened the bolts in his
neck to increase the blood flow to his
brain but even if a guy who actually
suffered brain damage knows what the
word illegal means and so his politics
of late have him leaning farther right
and fedman is embracing the Divergence
telling NBC quote I'm not a progressive
I just think I'm a Democrat that's very
committed to choice and other things but
with Israel I'm going to be on the right
side of that and immigration is
something something near and dear to me
and I think we do have to effectively
address it as well he also called out
fellow Democrat Bob Menendez for being
allowed to remain in office despite a
massive corruption Scandal a Democrat
calling out corruption you say that's
like Mr Olympia calling out
steroids little bodybuilding humor I got
it thank you man hey what's the problem
with
steroids Matt Matt thinks to himself but
it's true Federman Pro to have much more
of a brain than we gave him credit for
perhaps he has an extra one in his
tail but it's weird I mean as he
regained his brain function he also
became remarkably non-liberal it's what
I've been saying for years the more you
use your brain the less liberal you
become no surprise as we've seen what
happens to intelligence when you cut off
the oxygen supply to the
brain you know it means we owe JN an
apology or to put it another
[Music]
way we've made fun of you for months we
feel
ashamed we're so
sorry John
fed but we've seen the L and so tonight
we want to praise your name
[Applause]
oh so much
SM most Dan in
Washington it's true we're
[Applause]
sorry jeck could you have predicted that
John fedman would be the voice of reason
or is the barges really low in the
Democrats right now I am shocked that
I'm about to say anything positive about
John fedman I'm I can't believe he he's
like that one friend that surprises you
yeah like he's like that stupid dumb
friend and then you find out that he
knows how to play classical piano and
you're like what you're like I wasn't
expecting this and then he's like yeah
my parents made me play when I was a kid
but I never really liked it anyways help
me strap this firecracker to this
gopher you know like H it's so true
everybody has that friend and if you
don't then you are that friend
[Laughter]
Matt uh he sounds like you when it comes
to immigration you think this is going
to hurt him well you know I don't
believe people when they say I look
anything like him I don't know where
they I don't know where they see
that especially if I was to wear a black
hoodie that would look nothing like him
um you know this is actually the as he
you know recovers from his stroke I
think what's happening is he realizes
he's representing the people of
Pennsylvania and so he's interacting
with actually these working class
Americans that don't like woke ideology
they don't like the coastal Elites and
their policies and so he's trying to
represent them and probably like most
politicians save a skin for the next
election but you know at the end of the
day it's it's hard to look past and even
someone that you know suffered as
severely as he did it's you know he
can't look past this chaos at our
Southern border these videos that are
out today are just outrageous with the
people piling up uh and being allowed in
and so you know it makes sense but again
I think it's a you know if if he can
make calculations it's a political
calculation to actually represent the
people he represents interesting cat do
you think the stroke might have changed
him the way like when Spider-Man was
bitten by a
spider that's how it happened I think I
didn't I didn't take Spider-Man
history well a red white and blue spider
yeah as a
neurologist well why would you ask asked
me that question I don't
know anything can happen especially I
just watched you apologize to
somebody I've been doing that a lot I
yeah I know um kind of weird um I think
it's always a good thing when somebody
can actually break from what others in
their party are saying because that's
how stupid ideas take hold right it's
cuz people aren't really thinking
anymore they're just like oh this is
what everyone else is saying and rather
than actually think I'll just go with
that these are the people on my team but
that's how all this stupid stuff keeps
happening cuz people aren't thinking so
I think it's really really refreshing
this guy's thinking thinking for himself
he's willing to have his own opinion and
I think that's something to be
celebrated I agree completely and I like
being wrong because it means it's
surprising and it's fun to like oh maybe
I was too hard on the guy in The Green
Room uh Charlie you said I wish more
Democrats would have
strokes I thought that was
just all I was shocked it's true I was
shocked but you know that's your opinion
that's exactly what I said and I'm going
to defend it
now the um no this is the problem oh by
the way uh that's so true there's like a
whole breed of people who love to be
wrong because they like to be surprised
it's more interesting and and and good
people who get into newspapering are
people who' like to be surprised because
they're always curious and they make
good uh reporters the problem is when
they get like uh brainwashed and they
become stupid and then they don't they
look for confirmation as opposed to what
do I not know here it's it's exactly the
opposite of confirmation bias yes
exactly it's like I want to be proven
wrong yeah you know I love being
right but but but this is this whole
thing is it uh is kind of it underscores
what's so difficult about comedy and
news in DC today because like six months
ago the Babylon be did a joke headline
about this exact same thing and then it
starts happening for real like all of
the joke headlines wind up actually
coming to fruition kind of like all
conspiracies uh come to fruition but I
also love the fact that he's like
rejecting the term Progressive which I
don't really know what that means but
Democrats ruin every word they ever
that's why they keep having to go to the
next word they ruin the word Democrat
they ruin the word liberal and so then
now they're on Progressive and they're
ruining that word but the truth is he's
actually like a true liberal he believes
in he believes you shouldn't throw a
gays off a roof tops he believes that
you shouldn't like hate hate Jews you
shouldn't you know he's just like normal
and is like looking thinking critically
about things and you know we need more
of that yeah I wish we could debate
those last two
topics but we don't have time all right
up next men don't feel Sparks if women
quote Carl Marx hey Sean Hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere
else